look I like grapes too but time and
place hey there everybody nitpick rant
time and actually this will be the first
video where you get to see the new set
up it's not the first video I shot using
this setup so a little bit later on this
month you're gonna see a video where
I'll say it's the first time shooting
and it'll seem redundant with this
anyways so let's do a little nitpick on
a film that I love from a filmmaker I
adore but oh this drives me nuts Pan's
Labyrinth some actually including some
people very close to me argue that it is
the best film from acclaimed director
Guillermo del Toro a man of unique and
beautifully twisted vision a wonderful
imagination this is a terrific story
about a young girl in this wonderfully
dark fantasy world that begins to draw
her in as she's in the midst of the
Spanish Civil War which is its own kind
of horror she's dealing with real-world
horror fantasy horror at the same time
fantastic creatures amazing plot and
gorgeously shot terrific performances
but one scene the pale man scene let's
be clear problems not the pale man pale
man's awesome tell man is so incredibly
creepy and also like there's some
interesting reads that you can do on
that character as well as far as
possible meanings behind him but setting
that aside just viscerally it's
wonderfully inventively creepy and he's
terrific but God okay so the girl in
this sea
she is warned ahead of time by the fawn
who's also awesomely creepy both played
by Doug Jones both him and the pale man
hey Doug Jones is the man anyways she is
warned to not eat anything from the
feast that she sees and she is given
fairy guides and she has to go just a
draw a door and go through and there is
a limit amount of time before the door
shuts so she goes down this hallway
enters this dining hall there's the
banquet the feast
there's the pail man seems to be asleep
and then there's you know these locks
and there's a key thing she has to
figure out the right she does that she
gets what she came for everything's fine
and then she starts to leave and she
stops and looks at the food and goes for
great
[Applause]
this is the sort of thing that I suspect
is where Gamal Deltora leaned a little
bit too hard on this being fairytale
style story because that is the kind of
thing that would happen in a fairy tale
but the thing is the way you
traditionally hear a fairy tale is by
reading it or more accurately to
tradition having it told to you and
somebody telling it to you would have
given you insight into this girl's
thought process as to why the hell did
she do that I can come up with a
bajillion headcanons as to why but
there's nothing on screen explaining why
does the food have a kind of hypnotic
effect on her she is she tries telefon
later she didn't think anyone would
notice does she actually believe that or
is that her excuse later because nothing
about her performance seems to think ooh
I'll be sneaky and get away with this
there wasn't any kind of setup like Oh
grapes
the most amazing thing I'd do anything
for grapes in my memory there had been a
thing about like she hadn't had dinner
or something but that's not in there I
like my head was trying to plug the
holes and had decided that that was part
of the story but it's not she just grabs
a grape but it's worse than that she
doesn't just grab the grape she looks at
the grape and one of the fairies gets up
in front of hers like then she waves it
off then she plucks the grape and
another fairy she waves it off again
these are the things guiding you they
are trying to guide you to the world you
want to be in and you're ignoring them
and ignoring the fun to have a grape not
to mention the fact that there's a timer
still going you are wasting time in here
for a grape so many things that could
have been done to make
this more plausible if they'd had
something like she annoyed the captain
and was denied dinner or if there been
some sort of sense of magical war from
these things that was going to entice
her and like override her good senses
that's not really established again I
would have bought it would have made
total sense
none of these things are in here though
all that we watch is a girl who wants to
please these fairies ignore instructions
from the faun and then two warnings from
the fair heck it would have helped him
even just the fairies hadn't been so
articulated in such a normal human way
if they've been more like zipping around
little balls of light that didn't that
couldn't just state in a normal human
fashion then maybe they would have come
across as just knowing and her brushing
them off like bugs would have made more
sense but no they're little people
and their body language is super clear
no don't do that and she brushes the
what is wrong with you why are you being
so freakin stupid and I know you're a
kid and I try and make allowances for it
that child characters younger characters
are allowed to do stupider things
because well maybe they don't properly
understand the consequences but there is
nothing nothing that makes sense about
this even when through that lens I can't
buy it she's trying to save her mother
there's a timer that's gonna trap her
she has been warned but upon these
theories she has some of these things
that because she's booked in the mural
at the front and he's children and she
Grist it all for two grapes I'm sorry
that really takes me out of the movie
because it stretches the credulity of
the character and that's my one nitpick
with this otherwise brilliant freakin
film so that's that's my rant on that
what do you what are your thoughts about
this did I ruin the movie for you did
that bug you before am I the only one I
don't know whatever is the case drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it you
stuff to do you know what it is like
subscribe I got a patreon I have another
channel links for appropriate things are
down in the description go ahead and
click them or you also don't have to
these are not a commands I'm not giving
you a task that you must do by the full
moon do as you will eat a grape it's
fine
because at the end of the day you're the
council I'm just running the meetings
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]